what's up y'all so you guys all know
that spider-man exists in the multiverse
right right and with that comes a couple
of universes at least where there are
the worst spider-man that exists right
so i thought like maybe we should depict
what the worst spider-man would look
like i figured that the worst spider-man
would also cause the worst accidents if
there's a series of tragic events that
happens because of a spider-man's uh
misdoings that's gonna lead to blood and
violence what i love about this idea is
that the whole idea of like a multiverse
and the idea of infinity is that every
possible permutation of any type of
action has happened in one of those
universes so whatever we do it's canon
oh yeah he's like eating a deli sandwich
one day and he forgets to wipe his hands
off and he's like carrying somebody's
safety and they just slip right out
spiderman grabbing people and then
constantly dislocating the shoulder
the only joke is yeah
we brought in resident expert peter for
this one now you may not have seen him
for a while but there he is in the flesh
i would argue that i have an
encyclopedic knowledge of spider-man
you've shattered records uh in terms of
how many people have asked where you are
i had to sign an nda not talking about i
i got fired if it's okay to say yeah
okay
i put together a series of clips
[Music]
dude just what we're talking about yeah
exactly exactly this is such an iconic
scene for me i'd love to do something
it's rated r i'd love to do something
where his face is like really stuff come
here baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah it is you can tell that it's done
double too
so right there the arms immediately come
straight off okay and so it's just like
armless spiderman it's like now what i
do that was when that other guy has like
got any bright ideas
like i got a few and then he kicks off
his boots and use the web shooters that
we didn't know about honestly oh
yeah i love it and he kind of like then
grabs onto it with his toes then he like
falls forward but his feet are still
attached and he ends up turning into a
cheese grater along the train tracks
just like slicing off parts of his head
to his knees grinding down to a nub yeah
well it is a multiverse there could be
multiple ways they pass each other on
the tracks sam's done with it i mean
this is just
i don't know what to do with this yet
and then of course and then you know
this is also cut to clinton oh look at
that
i'm gonna die
[Music]
oh boy i mean we know it's coming here
right yeah that's pretty much what that
is it's just a mist comes out a fine
test that's what we got so far great
what do you think some good options very
excited about these effects yeah me too
dude we have a bunch of clips here to
work with so let's make this stuff
r-rated and um offend our grandmothers
so i'm tasked with taking all of these
fun little scenes where we're killing
spider-men and marrying them together
into a sort of story right and i'm
trying to figure out how it's all going
to work together i thought that the best
way to kind of bring these stories
together of this multiverse is through
the eyes of mobius who is in the show
loki mobius is basically a time cop he
goes through all the alternate timelines
in the multiverse and prunes them
eliminating any timeline that is uh a
bad a bad boy these spider-man are
causing mayhem and chaos so he's going
through all of these timelines and
eliminating them what that means is i
have to place owen wilson who plays
mobius into all of these other
spider-man scenes it was a lot of just
going through the entire show picking
the best scenes that helped tell her
story and then using those scenes uh
rotoing out owen wilson and placing him
in other scenes um so we need a bunch of
shots of owen wilson looking down at
things so that we can then put inserts
of a notepad which i'm trying to figure
out what the best notepad is you can use
my notepad your notepad is ridiculous
i'm out of paper i'm not even joking
never mind i take it back yeah fired
you're out of here but that's not the
only trick up my sleeve because we also
have
an incredible owen wilson impersonator
jet puffed marshmallows from a camping
trip with the family
and he's coming in today
how are you a pleasure having the one
and only owen wilson i woke up in my van
in malibu a couple of my shaman friends
last night climbed k2 oh wow um but
that's what we call kevin spacey's house
because
vince vaughn's thinking of buying it so
we went up there to cleanse the place
with some polishing time
i mean i'm doing some base jumping and i
just woke up in malibu on the sand oh
and then the first thing that happens
i immediately see a dolphin and i'm like
wow
then i turn on my radio and it's mama's
in the papa's california dream oh wow
yeah couldn't have planned it yeah
anymore
and then it follows up with monday
monday and it's a monday what we need
from our talented actor peter gilroy is
a narration that helps drive our story
and fill in the gaps where we need it so
i've already written a script for this
he's also a very funny comedian so i'm
hoping that we can get a lot of fun
stuff that we never expected we want all
those little like because you have
you've studied owen wilson for a very
long time
i've corrected i loved him i've just
loved him and it just naturally happened
i don't know if i have perfect owen
pitch but i just
just grew up watching him in will
ferrell movies vince vaughn vince vaughn
will ferrell love those guys
yeah we're pals we're amigos it's all
big one bendito is combined the the key
to owen wilson is the softness you'd
think he'd be over performing or you
think he'd get loud in certain like
emotional moments in a scene but he
quiets down i like how he's quiet it's
like i like how he's gentle and sweet
and loving and he has some of the best
vibes in hollywood and all in all the
land yeah he gets he gets almost down to
a whisper his house is on fire he's like
what is going on
it's so hot in here help me help help
anybody help a fire department we can
call are they our amigos are they our
parents
can we form a bond with the fire
department
he'd never be able to call for help ever
get so quiet he's a little voice up in
the room oh i think he might need
something
yeah i appreciate you uh coming out
giving us all of your owen wilson that
you've had left in you that's insane
namaste foreign
there's a scene from homecoming spider
home coming coming of homes homecoming
far from home home yeah far yeah no far
from homes than you were no no way i'm
so confused look i haven't eaten all day
i've got uber eats on the way he'll be
here in six minutes challenge accepted
can i get this whole breakdown done in
six minutes you bet i can spider-man is
trying to rescue his friends from a
scary elevator accident and then a
helicopter comes in and he tries to
swing a ding-ding around the helicopter
so here's the original shot let's take a
look at that he clears it because he's
spider-man but what if he didn't and
they just chop him up like a meat
grinder what are the steps i've gotta do
in order to make this shot a reality
first off i need to track in a clean
plate because i gotta erase spider-man
out of the shot pull from just little
bits of the image where he's not
covering it compile that all into one
big clean plate so here's the clean
plate right voila no spiderman
the next step is of course you've got a
rotoscope out spiderman because what
i've decided to do here is do this
completely in 2d no 3d elements here i'm
going to take the rotoscope spiderman
and slice it into a couple different
layers here
but then of course it doesn't work
without a tremendous amount of blood
elements but not just blood also these
dust hits that you tint red so you can
kind of get that like misty blood sort
of look and then of course you have the
actual blood splatter that you track to
the helicopter because it's to get
missed it's right underneath an
exploding spider-man you know what's
funny it's like this isn't actually all
that good in terms of like polish but
oh my god he's here my uber's here but
as long as you can kind of nail the
velocities and the motion and stuff like
that it feels more right now i'm gonna
go get my food and i'll show you the 3d
model that i spliced up
you look familiar do i uh corridor yeah
this is corridor oh my god really
yeah great
i love how you guys did the star wars
with uh oh the d-pick yeah yeah yeah oh
my god we're doing we're doing
spider-man rated r and i'm like filming
my breakdown right now
that's great yeah yeah thanks a lot man
take care have a good night
it's hilarious
i'm going to edit my tip thanks for
watching mauricio
the thing
before i'm munching crunch i gotta
finish this breakdown before i break
down he just got chopped up right so
basically i threw this model into a
voronoi fracture and what that does is
it takes your 3d model and breaks it up
into chunks so the idea is that i'm just
going to throw this into a simple rigid
body simulation tumbling through the air
you give it some initial velocity some
initial rotation
and poof got all these pieces falling
and they fall fall fall and then they
hit the ground and i'm able to use just
this one simulation for i think three
different shots dude i'm getting crazy
now i gotta eat i'm gonna get a burger
in my stomach
hey everyone it's me brandrew garfield
live from new york city back to tell you
about today's sponsor expressvpn now you
may have figured out in this video that
all the spidermen are complete and utter
disasters and i gotta say if you're not
using today's sponsor expressvpn your
internet experience is probably also a
complete and utter disaster and here's
why because expressvpn gives you
additional encryption and just like i
have this spidey suit on here to hide my
real identity expressvpn's additional
encryption is gonna add a layer of
security to all the internet data that
you put out onto the open internet which
means you're gonna be protected from
hackers and other people who can steal
your information and use it maliciously
and in addition to that the best thing
that expressvpn does is give you access
to tvs and movies that might not
otherwise be available in your country
or region they do this because they have
servers in over 94 countries and in even
more regions and you can access the
internet through those servers thereby
telling websites you're in a completely
different place they've been rated
number one by cnet and tech radar which
means you're going to get some of the
fastest speeds available and they have
24 7 customer support and they're
available on every device every time you
need them they're going to be there for
you if you're interested in getting
three months for free when you sign up
for a year head on over to
expressvpn.com
corridor crew and that's exactly what
you're going to get that's
e s e-x-p-r-e-s
vpn dot com slash core or crew and
you're gonna get three months free when
you sign up for a year anyways i'm gonna
get back to fighting crime and stopping
all these other bad spider-man from
being bad spider-man see you later dudes
i opted to do one very particular shot
of tobey maguire swinging full force
into a concrete wall i have intended to
explode a body in houdini for a long
time now and this seemed like the
perfect opportunity it's rated r right
that's what we're going for first things
first we're all wearing clothes right we
should be wearing clothes we start with
a recreation of the shirt pants and
shoes that toby was wearing and with a
little vellum simulation a little bit of
outside pressure through what are called
metaballs which are just basically
forces applied from the inside of the
cloth out you're able to create this
explosive effect of cloth just ripping
and flying everywhere we got the clothes
off now we want to get that skin off
which is the exact same process you just
do the same thing you put a force inside
a body all the skin is pre-cut when it
explodes out those cuts tear so that you
got a full-on explodey boy now what's
inside the body right we got blood and
we got bits step one was hunky monkey
chunks right i feel like that's a ben
and jerry's flavor the large chunks
first these are your your thigh chunks
your feet your head your hands like the
larger pieces of the body those chunks
bring a lot of weight to the explosion
so i did another sim and exploded that
it explodes into little tiny chunks
putting those together with the big
chunks with the clothes with the skin
you start to get a really nice look but
at this point it's way too dry so we
gotta bring that wetness out i actually
did a kind of like a faux liquid sim is
the first stage of this thing it's what
we call a grain simulation it's actually
a vellum simulation kind of like cloth
but it treats particles as like wet sand
when you blow it up you've got these
like nice stringy long chunks that stick
together it's pretty gross but it serves
the purpose of giving you like another
level right and now we reach our moist
finale i wish i never said that one
we've got our blood sprays we want to
feel how wet this thing is what am i
talking about so i did three separate
blood passes i did the very thin splashy
blood which is great for the initial
impact as it flies out all over the
place and then i did the second pass
with a little viscosity in the blood the
real nasty blood so it hits the wall and
this stuff sticks to the wall but a lot
of it will drip down and i did two
layers of this i did a somewhat viscous
blood simulation and an incredibly
viscous blood simulation and then last
but not least underneath all of that i
figured it would be cute to add the
bones of tobey maguire this whole thing
is pretty cartoony anyway now you've got
a situation where you've got a dent in
the in the wall with the skeleton inside
when the blood oozes down and around
it's oozing out of that hole in the wall
and around the bones of the skeleton and
that makes a big difference for the
final product i still need to render
this stuff out and composite so you'll
have to wait to the end of the video to
see the final but uh i'm feeling pretty
good about it
we're making spider-man r rated we're
tackling the best spider-man movie the
amazing spider-man 2. the spider-man
that dared to ask what if spider-man was
like hot you know gwen stacy she's there
to die she's a character that's
specifically made for the spider-man
universe in order to get killed without
her being mary jane watson this is the
origin of look at that neck by the way
look at that neck dude look at that next
nap snap
he catches her with the web
and then whiplash it's tasteful okay no
blood no guts but that's not how we do
things around here at quarter crew okay
she needs to not even get caught by the
web no open casket funeral for gwen
stacy okay it's not like you can just
recontextualize footage of gwen stacy
following we we don't have footage so
that means you have to build a gwen
stacy you know emma stone's not one of
those actresses that has like a bunch of
weird fans that like make 3d models of
her why is there no models of emma stone
online i
weird sex guy
3d model guys get on it put emma stone
on cg trader okay so i had to make a
model of emma stone i used a character
creator to project emma stone's head
shot onto like a rudimentary 3d model
but that ended up being useless because
i made her land face down anyway i mean
it's pretty close to what she's wearing
so that's gonna be good enough and
that's how we do vfx here at corridor
digital we have our model of gwen stacy
we throw her into mixamo wonderful site
plenty of lovely motion capture
animations that are just pre-made for
you here's a lovely maximo animation
somebody falling and landing really
really hard and then that ends up with
me having a model of
emma stone hitting the ground black mask
everybody out and then after effects has
a feature called content aware fill
which is the greatest thing ever so we
put our 3d model on top of our clean
plate it doesn't even look good so we're
going to just build up our layers right
you need to have blood mist so her body
just emits like a fine powder because
that's how bodies work blood splatters
that that all animate on she needs to
like leave like like a cloud of dust
there is one more element spider-man
comes down and lands right on top of her
creating the amalgamation of the tube
the ultimate fusion of male and female
eight legs a human spider
corpse thing
hey
let's make a train sequence given the
amount of new shots i was going to have
to create from scratch i decided to
recreate the entire scene in cgi why not
it's easy we can buy models on the
internet they're cheap so i bought some
models of new york buildings i bought a
train model and a model of spiderman and
i tailored them to fit my needs i
modeled some tracks okay so for the shot
where toby's arm is getting ripped off
we take our cg arm and the first thing i
did to that was i simulated the both the
cloth and the skin tearing apart with
like a cloth simulation so they dangled
a little bit then i grabbed some models
of muscles and veins and i did another
light cloth simulation on top of those
to make them flap around a bit and look
gross and that was looking pretty good
but really the cherry on top of these
shots is the blood spurts the blood on
the lens and the camera shade the camera
shake really is doing most of the work
here who are we kidding the most
difficult shots though were the ones
where i had to completely remove toby's
arms and add bloody stumps instead and
so for that i decided to just go the
full cg route so i was just like
everything's cg so we have the existing
shot as our background plate and then we
3d track the camera of that so then we
can bring in our cg train to slap on top
of it covering toby's arms and removing
that problem and then we take our cg
model of spider-man put that on top of
toby and use the background footage as a
reference to exactly animate and match
the movements of his body in the shot
frame by frame going through moving it
tweaking it rotating it which is a time
consuming process but honestly it's like
not that bad it took me like 20 minutes
and i threw some bloody stumps on there
for the arms and render that out cut out
toby's head slap it back on top and
you're good to go
this is our pruning baton or what do
they call what do they call in the show
a time
stick a time stick we have this big
showdown at the end of our piece which
requires us to have mobius and dark toby
bully mcguire fighting each other so we
have to take two separate scenes and
marry them together somehow by lifting
them from their respective scenes and
putting them in our own background
plates that we'll be shooting here in a
second so he's very backlit with just a
uh an orange key the background doesn't
necessarily need to have all those
elements but it needs to imply that some
of the light is bouncing of the certain
objects what that also requires is a
couple of inserts where we have our
pruning baton stabbing basically we're
going to track in the cg element back
into our hands for the inserts
[Music]
mine aren't getting wet
there you go the day's finally come this
video is finished and we're going to
show it to everyone right here let's go
keep on snapping everybody keep on
snapping i have not seen any of the owen
wilson stuff that you've put into this
so far i've not seen all of your shots i
don't really know what to expect here
other than i'm extremely excited dude me
too i have been dying yes it's been hard
all week like resisting the urge to like
look at your computer monitors and stuff
we're giving you the thing they won't
show you in movies
a spider guy really messed things up
i'm mobius by the way i specialize in
erasing undesirable realities in
multiverse and this clean cut peter
parker just created a whole mess of
undesirable
i mean he made branching timelines that
contain some of the most incompetent
spider-man the tva has ever seen
i'll tell you what
i'm gonna prune every last one of them
[Music]
telly how
i'm gonna die
[Music]
you have a train to catch
ideas you gotta
we're slowing down
[Music]
only one timeline left to prune
the worst spiderman of them all
now take off this
[Music]
what's up penis parker
[Applause]
that was an experience i'm out of breath
i just say peter that was
insane thank you in the greatest way
imaginable thank you oh my gosh blown
away it just kept going and getting it
kept topping itself
when i first saw this my jaw was like oh
the muscle terror
the webbing of the costume popping out
is such a good detail dude
[Laughter]
dude those simulations oh that was
insane oh thank you when you're working
on it i just kept seeing the layers
develop as i turn around just more blood
more viscosity mr smoothie
spider blender oh
literally i'll just watch the
effortlessly
oh my god that's so good this is so
funny just a comp scene
that's it's just so funny
wait what's that what's that shot
is that from a that's from yeah they say
penis parker and yeah that's the that's
the famous the famous line by tony
ravioli when you were doing that shot
you knew in the end it was gonna be like
mosaiced out so did you just put like a
cg cylinder in there or no he used a
photo scan okay
i actually did the exact same thing that
i did for the dinosaur tail in jurassic
park turns out spline dynamics work on
both ends
so
and if you guys subscribe to corridor
digital.com you can see it without no no
no no no no no
no we you don't so if you're just
watching this video for the first time
of anything we've got four spiderman
videos coming out this weekend we got
not spiderman everyone's got super
powers
well everyone but me vfx artists react
to spiderman twos those other ones came
out yesterday and this guy is up on uh
the quarter channel as well
[Applause]
i think it deserves
oh
all right
you guys should comment below for others
uh weird r-rated ideas uh we'll do it
hopefully also like and subscribe if you
like this because we're gonna do a lot
more of these in the future because it
was such a blast thanks for watching